[Musique]
les chants traditionnels ont ouvert
l'arrivée des officiels à la chapelle
pointue un moment solennel pour
symboliquement libérer de leurs chaînes
et trois frères esclaves de saint-leu
[Musique]
cette musique a ensuite conduit la
délégation vers le camp baron de villèle
une reconstitution pour ne pas casser
les faire les faire et les chaînes et le
reste est venu par la suite
mais pendant toute cette période là
c'est à dire pratiquement jusqu'en 1936
fin de du colonat et bien ça a été à peu
près les mêmes bases avec interdiction
de les améliorer
parqués à l'intérieur des cabanes sous
des notes de liberté l'ambiance pas un
écho empreint d'émotion
non
on s'est engagé un engagement collectif
pour lutter je dirais contre la copie de
et là aussi je dirais 7 cet engagement
je dirai au quotidien c'est aussi un
engagement 1 pour préserver sa liberté
pour préserver je dirais sa santé c'est
justement bien de se replonger dans
l'histoire pour analyser ce qu'elle a
été et mesurer aussi tous les combats
qui doivent être les nôtres aujourd'hui
lors de cette cérémonie a été effectué
une présentation technique de ce qui
sera le futur musée de villèle
il deviendra le musée de l'histoire de
l'habitation et de l' esclavage
alors l'idée effectivement c'est de ne
pas affirmer un discours d'une vérité
unique mais de présenter une vérité
partagée par tous les acteurs de cette
histoire des historiens des philosophes
des sociologues des anthropologues mais
aussi des témoins de cette histoire les
acteurs de cette histoire et ceux aussi
qui sont les porteurs de l'histoire des
laissés pour compte de l'histoire c'est
une prise de conscience quand même
relativement récente et c'est une prise
de conscience qui qui peut l'être parce
que il ya aussi une évolution du
cessionnaire nouveau bâtiment une vision
plus élargie de l'histoire de coire en
hommage aux anciens et ainsi décidé de
construire l'avenir en pleine conscience
libéré du passé
du
utile
[Musique]